It's time for us to talk about two
basic types of neurotransmission:
excitation and inhibition.
Excitation and Inhibition require
a delicate and orchestrated balance
between pre- and postsynaptic processes.
Signal transmission is
mediated by neurotransmitters
that are released presynaptically
AND by a large complexity
of postsynaptic mechanisms
and signalling pathways.
The processes of
excitation and inhibition
occur because this wild
assortment of mechanisms
mediate postsynaptic potentials.
Presynaptically, the cast of
characters is quite simple.
We will see, for example, that fast
excitatory postsynaptic potentials are
mediated primarily by
cation-selective ion
channels in the postsynaptic neuron,
alongside a host of other complex and
diverse postsynaptic players involved
in signalling pathways.
Comparatively, the presynaptic
terminal is less of a party.
Back in the postsynaptic terminal,
fast inhibitory postsynaptic potentials
are mediated primarily by
anion-selective ion channels.
However, our simple, quiet
little neurotransmitters,
waiting in the presynaptic terminal
for their action potential,
are absolutely necessary to
trigger postsynaptic mechanisms.
What's so remarkable is the fact
that the delicate excitation-inhibition
balance throughout the brain can
be achieved with just a handful
of different types of
neurotransmitters and ions.
For example, metabotropic receptors
like GPCRs will sense a neurotransmitter
and activate specific
signal transduction pathways
that ultimately change ion permeability
and other processes inside the cell.
Other postsynaptic players,
like AMPA and NMDA receptors,
which mediate excitatory
communication and synaptic plasticity
in the central nervous system, are
permeable to many types of ions.
The party is happening postsynaptically!